scarlet witch's turn to villainy the
introduction of the x-men and the return
of tony stark according to a leaked list
of characters exclusively obtained by
looper doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness is set to have more shocking
moments than spider-man no way home and
avengers end game combined warning
massive spoilers ahead won that
what do you know about the multiverse
the movie's plot reportedly follows dr
strange wong and mordo as they work to
fight back the invasive forces of a
collapsing multiverse fending off such
legendary marvel terrors as schumachura
known in the movie as gargantos
they also contend with new friends and
foes in the form of dr strange's
interdimensional variants including a
corrupted sinister strange a heroic
defender strange and reportedly even an
amusing powerless strange a foot surgeon
from philadelphia who's relatively
unambitious and wants nothing to do with
cosmic mayhem look i'm fusing transected
spinal cords i'm stimulating
neurogenesis in the central nervous
system work i'm doing is going to save
thousands for years to come in their
travels they'll also meet the mysterious
america chavez a teenager with the
ability to travel between dimensions but
that's all stuff we know from the
trailers looper has exclusively obtained
a list of leaked characters set to
appear in the film let's take a trip
into the multiverse and meet the rest of
the characters as the trailers have
teased we're getting a live action
glimpse at a secret super team of marvel
characters known as the illuminati we
can finally confirm this rumor we'll
meet dr charles xavier played once again
by patrick stewart and no despite the
resemblance it's not the charles xavier
you're familiar with
let us go talk to the professor
mcavoy or stuart these timelines are so
confusing
there's also black bolt the inhuman from
the tv show once again played by anson
mount
he would say nice to meet you but if he
talks he destroys the world
[Music]
we're then introduced to a new
live-action mcu character played by an
actor fans were begging for john
krasinski is reed richards the one and
only mr fantastic turns out that fan
cast wasn't a stretch after all finally
a mic drop moment for the arrival or is
that revival of tony stark played in
this reality by superstar tom cruise
that's classified
according to our sources the illuminati
will be interrupted by an
interdimensional portal that takes
everyone by surprise who's the intruder
it's andrew garfield is peter parker
being chased by paul giamani the rhino
from the amazing spider-man 2.
garfield's peter finally gets a chance
to meet an alien when a variant of
carnage played by woody harrelson but
known here as arachnia emerges from a
portal to join the battle next up it's
dr michael morbius the living vampire
himself the multiverse has officially
opened
and that's not all pursuing morbius
through the interdimensional portal that
he travels through is blade played by
wesley snipes making his official debut
in the mcu there's still a war going on
and i have a job to do
and he's assisted by blade played by
mahershala ali making his official debut
in the mcu
after the dust settles on these
multiversal scuffles a great rumbling is
heard in the illuminati's hall according
to our leaker the next scene is quote
kind of like the scene in matrix
reloaded where 10 000 agent smiths jump
on neo except it's every marvel
character ever coming in for a huge
punch party we'll get chris evans as
captain america versus chris evans as
johnny storm and michael b jordan as
eric killmonger versus michael b jordan
as johnny storm get ready to see every
loki variant again get ready for both
black widows again sound crazy
don't
don't call me crazy i'm not crazy the
multiverse is cracked open by this point
setting the stage for superman versus
batman versus batman vs spider-man vs
spider-man vs spider-man versus four
different versions of the joker the
definition of epic it is how did it say
like yoda because yoda's in the movie
people disney owns marvel disney owned
star wars it was only a matter of time
this will be our link from to the marvel
universe from the star wars universe
just when you thought things couldn't
get crazier the hot blade of a laser
sword pierces through dimensions it's a
digitally de-aged cgi luke skywalker but
wait there's another a digitally dh cgi
princess leia then a digitally dhcgi
patrick stewart play in a different
xavier than the xavier we already saw
joined by james mcavoy taking on the
role of a deep fake jean-luc picard
next up mario played by chris pratt he's
so cool shadow the hedgehog will kill
doctor strange and that's not all not by
a long shot according to our trustworthy
leaker earthworm jim will finally make
his movie debut with doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness after showing
up in the pages of marvel comics in
1995.
truly who else we already mentioned that
chris pratt would play super mario but
what about dr mario dr strange isn't the
only md to go multi-dimensional chris
pratt will also play the legendary dr
mario that's a prescription for fun i
think we're done with leaks think again
you complete munch remember mark
wahlberg's turn as elliott moore from
2008's hit movie to happening what no
our leaker tells us that wahlberg will
enter the multiverse fray because the
fans demanded it and he's not the only
mark who's gonna make his mark on the
marvel multiverse there's no better way
to experience the multiverse than in the
metaverse and that's the opportunity
that mark zuckerberg will offer to those
who stream doctor strange through the
oculus quest on opening night zuck will
play the voice of his own disembodied
digital head which floats beyond the
action in every scene delivering fan
favorite zuckerberg catch phrases sweet
baby ray's barbecue sauce zuckerberg
will only be visible to viewers viewing
the film via oculus quest with oculus
quest you can strap facebook to your
face do it do it our linger says there's
more more more who else comes through
the portal to slap dr strange's bare
bottom that's right beetlejuice
beetlejuice beetlejuice been about 600
years after all i wonder where a guy and
everyday joe like myself
could find a little action
the ghost with the most is back in a big
big big way with michael keaton signing
on to join the overwhelming cast of
multiverse of madness reprising his role
as beetlejuice and the vulture and
batman now you want to get nuts come on
let's get nuts also returning is winona
ryder is lydia dietz talk about doctor
stranger things who else plus who else
doctor strange will be joined by dr phil
and dr oz and dr pepper and mr peanut mr
peanut is back also mr met and mr bean
pretty sure the veggie tails will also
show up tails tails tail spin oh yeah we
got blue flying the sea duck up in this
and the rescue rangers roger rabbit
curious george paddington magic mike
martin scorsese zoolander a young
benedict cumberbatch fresh out of acting
camp bernie mac from mr 3000 those
dinosaurs from the craft mac and cheese
commercials in the 90s they're back
they're all coming back
you broke through the window
you followed me all the way here oh no
get off
me no
no take me back no
i promise i'll be good no no not the
handcuffs
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one